when you're graphing a rational function
how do you know when you have a slant
asymptote or a diagonal asset order or
an oblique asymptote those all mean the
same thing well you know because the
degree of the highest power term in the
numerator is one degree higher than the
highest degree term in the denominator
so see how this is x squared and this is
X to the first that's how we know we
have a slant asymptote but how do we
find the equation of that slant
asymptote that's what we're gonna do
here I'm going to show you two different
methods this first method because this
is a linear factor so it's like X plus
something or X minus something we can
use the synthetic division to find our
slant asymptote the way you do that is
if this is X plus 2 and to put negative
2 here and I'm going to put our
coefficients in the numerator here 2x
squared is 0 ax if there's not an X term
and negative 3 so to do that synthetic
division you drop down that first number
two you multiply on the diagonal you add
straight down you multiply on the
diagonal you add straight down this is
your remainder this last number since
we're dividing by X to the first this is
going down by one degree so we went from
two x squared - 2 X to the first - 4 so
y equals 2x - 4 is the equation of our
slant asymptote now sometimes you can't
use this method like an example number 2
where this is a see how this is a
quadratic in the denominators this is a
second degree we're gonna have to do
long division so let me show you that
one again notice the degree in the
numerator is x cubed this is one degree
less x squared that's how we know we
have a slant asymptote but what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to do the
long division and show you how to get
the equation of the slant asymptote now
you might be saying Mario how come you
didn't do anything with this 5 over here
well the 5 the remainder see you take
the remainder and you put it over the
divisor which is X plus 2 but as X gets
larger and larger meaning as you go to
the right on the graph this quantity
here is going to get smaller and smaller
it's going to approach 0 so we just end
up with the quotient here you don't have
to worry about the remainder because
that term is going to go to 0 so but for
number 2 here we're gonna do the long
division so x squared goes into X cubed
how many times that's one time I
distribute the X I get X you
plus four X I subtract okay so these are
going to cancel this gives us 3x squared
plus twelve and then how many times does
x squared go into X up to 3x squared
that's three times so my distribute I
get 3x squared plus twelve I subtract
you can see there's a zero remainder but
you don't have to worry about the
remainder just the quotient here so y
equals x plus three is going to be our
slant asymptote for this rational
function if you want to see more about
graphing rational functions check out
the video right there and I'll see over
in that video if you're joining my my
videos subscribe to the channel my goal
for you is to make learning math less
stressful so you can raise your grade
pass your class and go on to pursue your
dreams I'll see you in my future videos